What answer did you come up with, David?
Is two the correct answer?
>> So
I said that that was the correct answer.
It looks to me like the relationships
at play in frame A and
frame C are the same.
And the relationships at play in
frame B and frame 2 are the same.
We saw that x was unchanged between
the two frames, just as r is.
Y expanded, just s does.
And z was deleted, just as t is.
Similarly, y was above x,
just as s is above r.
So I think it's the right answer.
>> Good David,
that's in fact the correct answer.
Two is the best choice of a level here.
But imagine that for 2 s row,
the match between the representation
on the left side and the representation
on the right side was only partial.
Just like it was when
we had five over here.
How then would we make a choice
between two and five, David?
>> So it sounds like so
far we've been talking about an
all-or-nothing match of transformations.
But if we didn't have an exact
match between the transformations,
we'd have to come up with some
way to evaluate how well two
transformations actually fit together.
So we might say that these
transformations are 95% similar,
while these two are only 70% similar.
So that would allow us to
choose one over the other.
>> That sounds fair.
In fact, we'll come across
something like this very soon.